stop doing what to who go right tell me
yeah I'm coming down if I no one shoots
me I'll shoot back yeah how tall are we
making him this is too tall this is
hello baby
hello baby are you behind me didn't
think so
run what done run what what happened my
beautiful breath Josh see some [ __ ] I've
got a grenade I've got a grenade I've
got a grenade got a grenade I saw
someone in that bathroom you come out of
that bathroom you're dead really cuz I
got a grenade
okay holy crap
right things are just things are really
really mother [ __ ] you son of a [ __ ]
you're in plain sight that's like hiding
behind objects were like the hunters
can't really see okay you're fine after
the clap do it on shoot do it on shoot
three two one the developer knows that I
would probably not listen to the
narrator ergo I probably should listen
to the narrator while I'm not going
through with what the narrator tells me
to do and since Adair and he wants me to
go on the door the left but I would
normally not listen to them they're
there and go and go right the actual
correct answer would be on the right but
if I choose that then it would actually
be wrong ergo I should go left hope I
got you stop running that happy just get
too happy just get the happy just oh I
got the happy juice slug is a white boob
in his hand
for so long oh is he bleeding no mark
are you really what for it for real
markiplier highlight thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more then please leave a like to
let me know links to all the videos are
available in the description below so
check them out and if you have a
suggestion for a video you want to see
in a highlight reel let me know in the
comments thanks again everyone and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye